joining us now with reaction michelle
malkin investigates host on see our TV
michelle malkin foxnews national
security strategist former deputy
assistant to the president sébastien
corchia michelle your reaction to all of
this and this is really just the tip of
the iceberg mccabe it is the stench
emanating from the top echelon of the
FBI are beyond fetid I mean this is the
malodorous muck of the deep state swamp
and as desperate as the desperation
media is Shawn there is nothing they can
do to cover it up they'll keep repeating
the same tired false talking points
about this being some sort of partisan
witch hunt on the part of the Trump
administration that's pure psychological
projection and you can't hide the fact
that it was career FBI people and an
Obama appointee in Michael Horowitz so
you've got the IG within the Justice
Department and the Office of
Professional Responsibility that signed
off on this firing last Friday it has
nothing to do as you said Sean with
Donald Trump and and I think they you're
absolutely right you've been saying it
for a long time that this is the tip of
the iceberg and I have to say that as a
matter of historical context this did
not just come out of nowhere I reported
over the last eight years about how the
Obama administration and particularly
people in the Justice Department Ward it
at every turn inspector general's
investigations it happened at justice it
happened in the EPA interior tarp every
single one of these civilian agencies
and so you add the the national security
implications and dangers of the
hijacking of our intelligence agencies
and yes a hijacking of a constitutional
crisis and it's do undermine a duly
elected president and to assist a felon
law breaker and and literally exonerate
somebody who committed many laws that is
a constitutional crisis let me go to dr.
korkor you have rice your clapper you
have Brennan you have Comey you have
paid you have struck you have Loretta
Lynch you
have the Obama administration top-down
absolutely
let's remember you know this individual
Andy McCabe he's he's just a small part
of a massive conspiracy and and again
the OPR it sounds very anodyne the
Office of Professional Responsibility
that's the IAD of the FBI that's the
Internal Affairs Division and they said
this guy cannot get his pension that is
a must massive blow and it's just the
beginning but now comes the real test
Sean
now AG sessions has to clean the stable
counsel right special counsel all right
guys you've been amazing thank you all
so much